foreign
house come on in let me show you around
come into the living room
it looks updated lovely lovely but we
have a new toy you've seen these in
Banks where they send things back and
forth well this only goes one way this
is the new way that the house guest will
hear messages and updates from us when
they hear
uh oh Big Brother's kicking off season
25 with a brand new house and we've got
an exclusive look inside with host Julie
Chen moonves the Big Brother Multiverse
is the theme for season 25 what does
that mean that means the game has turned
upside down Anything Could Happen expect
the unexpected more than ever we've
never had alternate universes like this
it took a crew of 22 people just over
eight weeks to design and build the new
digs where 16 house guests will battle
it out for the 750 000 prize but how was
this alternate universe really created
you can blame some returning house
guests for that Frankie Grande
Danielle Reyes and Brittany Haynes they
broke into the house thinking they could
change their fate they feel wronged that
they never won BB well their plan
backfired and the consequence was they
created the BB Multiverse I'm the
Phoenix rising from the ashes and now
I'd love to do it again because
um I'm six years sober and it would be
such a different ride I would be so much
more confident this time which I know
you all thought I was super confident
but like because I I mean I'm pretty
confident but like now it'd actually be
super confident authentically confident
which could be really fun
congratulations Brittany
you know I'm 51 now right I have nothing
to prove my life is great so imagine
playing the game when you don't care if
you're gonna lose
that you can create chaos
and just be so manipulative those three
past house guests are legends they are
three of the most memorable
um through the most clever house guests
we've ever had so when they broke in
they thought they might be able to
change their fate they didn't change
their own fate they changed the fate of
the 16 new house guests and what they're
in for this summer so does that mean
we'll see Frankie Danielle and Brittany
competing you never know I know they'd
like to we'll see what Universe these
former house guests live in and if it
will cross over with the BB Multiverse
you never know
anytime you see a lightning bolt in the
house you have entered
Another Universe this is one of a few
bedrooms and everything is upside down
just like the game this season I'm
walking on the ceiling so expect the
unexpected things are not always what
they appear it all kicks off tomorrow on
CBS with a 90-minute Premiere and lots
of Easter eggs celebrating this
Milestone anniversary so in this bedroom
things are obviously not right it's not
right it's not right to walk on the
ceiling these headlines are not right
for example it says a legend is born
Victoria plays The Hitman
no she didn't they played her next
headline the cookout is cooked no they
weren't they were the final six and
finally the doctor is out no the doctor
was in Dr will won season two so
everything is Bizarro World in here
things are not right
[Music]
this bedroom is very comical to me and
we have famous quotes from Big Brother
Zing who doesn't love a zingbot
bye bye
you can fill in the blank Janelle
everyone knows the same she said bye bye
side eye cat side eye cat made guest
appearance we never reuse props but
people love side eye cats so side eye
cat came back has its own following
this bedroom you would think is the
have-not room because it does not look
nice but actually it's not
check it out hands coming out of the
walls hands on the other side of that
wall very creepy and disturbing rust
dirt
beds that look like they are not up to
any code in any error that we've ever
lived in or ever seen in the Big Brother
house so this room is made for you to
not feel comfortable I'll just put it
this way it's a different universe
in the BB Multiverse
in the dining area we have two universes
in one room two different worlds
colliding the lightning bolt divides the
two universes that exist here one side
looks like the normal Big Brother house
for season 25 and the other side looks
like
a totally separate World which it is
what does that mean for the house guests
you have to stay tuned to find out
who ate the half
who can forget muffin gate oh yes we
have a muffin it's underseal take a look
at these cakes they look comical but
guess what they're real see things
aren't always the way they appear in the
Big Brother house or the game or this
season season 25 it says on the cake
expect the unexpected
you can eat that
the HOH bedroom is always the biggest
the most plush and it should be because
if you've won the title of headers
household you deserve it as always we
have the monitor where you can spy on
who is downstairs and who's hanging out
with who what are they doing
this is the power room of Big Brother
always has been and always will be fans
could expect more more bigger better
Wilder new twists new turns new faces
new 16 people new house guests we always
say expect the unexpected even I was
like wait what that's what fans should
expect fans can also expect 90 cameras
and 113 microphones to capture all the
action but then there's still the
old-fashioned way to find things out
this window is brand new a window to spy
on other house guests see who is
cavorting with who and what are they
talking about that's always the key to
big brother who's talking and about what
and is it about me expect the unexpected
[Music]
this bedroom makes me laugh every time
why because check it out everything in
here
will strip you of any Pride you have
when you come into this bedroom for
example instead of the sign it says you
are a winner crossed out no you are a
wiener this is a wiener bed not the most
comfortable place
everyone knows that Dr will Kirby called
himself the Puppet Master the sign says
total puppet
Master crossed out total puppet this bed
you need I think a Dramamine just to
like sleep in this
who wants to sleep on a wedge of cheese
or in the doghouse in a dog bed so this
room is designed so that you can laugh
at yourself as you're trying to compete
for three quarters of a million dollars
instead of you ruled no it says you
stink with a stinky piece of cheese
every house guest who leaves this room
has to First spin the wheel and
depending where the number lands oh my
gosh 25 they have to stand here
and have themselves kicked in the butt
25 times so you know what E.T as you
exit don't let the door or the foot kick
you on the way out of the BB house
[Music]